nuevamente la conmoción en Jerusalén
este luego de que un palestino con
ciudadanía israelí embistió con su
vehículo una parada de autobús
asesinando a dos personas incluido un
niño de seis años e hiriendo a varias
más el atacante murió tras los disparos
de las fuerzas israelíes en la escena de
los hechos la policía llegó rápidamente
pero el terrorista fue neutralizado por
un oficial de policía fuera de servicio
que estaba en el área neutralizando
hacia el terrorista y evitando que un
ataque terrorista se convirtiera en algo
más Severo
al ministro de seguridad de israelí y
tomar benhibir se hizo presente en el
lugar Mientras que el Primer Ministro
Benjamín se expresó desde su cuenta de
Twitter felicitando en accionar policial
en nombre de todos los ciudadanos de
Israel envió mis condolencias a las
familias de los asesinados en el ataque
en Jerusalén realicé una evaluación de
la situación de seguridad y ordene
aumentar las fuerzas realizará restos y
actuar de inmediato para sellar la casa
del terrorista y demolerla todos rezamos
por la paz de los heridos un portavoz de
jamás el grupo islamista que permanece
en gaza destacó el ataque y lo calificó
como una operación heroica Pero no se
atribuyó la responsabilidad la tensión
en la región ha aumentado Durante este
año en el que 43 palestinos han muerto
enredadas en sijordania siete israelí
fueron asesinados en un tiroteo a una
sinagoga y la administración israelí
intensifica demoliciones de viviendas
palestinas en Jerusalén este